hello everyone and welcome to a game I
myself would describe as perfect but you
know you'll just have to see it for
yourself it was played in round 8 of the
2018 single Cup between Shockley and
Mama DRF and the Magnus Carlsen so both
of them of course members of the 2800
club but before we check out the game I
do have something I need to bring your
attention to I hope you were all having
a wonderful Sunday and that you all had
an excellent weekend
I myself was having an excellent Sunday
but then I received an email from a
certain individual of the st. Louis
chess club now I would like to you to
pause the video here and read this email
just so you know what's what's going on
so for those of you who have read it
congratulations you are an excellent
subscriber and for those of you who
might have been a little lazy to read it
basically what they are saying or what
Tammy from st. Louis chess club is
saying that I have you know used the
copyrighted material from their live
feed from the 2018 Sinquefield Cup and
basically what they are saying that this
is copyright infringement and that they
require me to take down my videos that
that user uses those videos that use
their content now I have no idea what
content they are talking about and I've
sent them an email I've received no
reply the only reply I received was the
one where they politely asked that I
removed the tweet where I publicly
showed their email but the contents of
the email and the email but I did no
such thing because well under the US law
of fair use this pretty much screams as
fair use because what fair use is all
about is that you can use pretty much
any copyrighted materials for the use of
commenting you know the hand creating
parodies from at education pretty much
anything that isn't just for for
stealing content but as as I've always
said the higher held the the st. Louis
chess club in the highest regard this
this really upset me a little not too
much
it did upset me a little and now I have
no idea how this whole thing will turn
out but in case you one day decides to
visit my channel and the channel is gone
you know just so you know what happened
but yeah returning to the game like we
said it's sharma media versus magnus
cross and round 8 of the sinful cup and
like I said I really consider this to be
an almost perfect game but you'll see
what I mean
Mamedov has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 g6
Knight to f3 and Bishop to g7 so the
Kings Indian defense g3 c6 we have brush
up to g2 d5 Knight bTW - and here cousin
goes for a very rare move here he plays
a 5 and a 5 is basically an eventual
move because if one took used this move
on numerous occasions for example in
1999 he used that in the in the Monte
Carlo amber rapid tournament to draw his
game against Anatoly Karpov and also in
2015 he used it to defeat a rather slow
void Eric so here b3 is played by mom in
Europe like we said in 1999 Karpov
Castle - in this position
Mamiya of figures b3 is better we have a
four by Carlsen Bishop to a3 this is the
same as was played in the void
attractive and chilled game and here
cross and goes for a capture Sun b3 in
the void - eventually game once you've
decided to castle in this position but
okay we have a capture son b3 a capture
some b3 and castles by Colson we have
castles in the rook to e8 we have III
and the bishop to f5 f5 is a beautiful
square for this light square Bishop
slices all the way here to be one and
it's not all that easy to challenge this
bishop for example Knights to h4 does
challenge the bishop but then Bishop to
d3 is a move now the rook on f1 gets
under attack rook to e1 and now you have
a very nice Bishop on d3 you can simply
continue developing and if white ever
decides to attack it for example now
opens up an attack D captures on c4 the
bishop is guarded and the white will
lose the pawn here so a very nice work
for the bishop not all that easy to
counter it Queen to e2 now guarding
the d3 square and here comes Knight to
a6 here now you might think that okay
now that the queen is guarding d3 I
might I might actually go for this night
to h4 move but then Bishop to g4 is also
possible and now if you're not too sure
about it maybe you don't want to play a
move like f3 and you know open up your
King all this much so after a 6 we have
Knight to e5 it's always better to put
your knife on a nice central square then
put it on a funny square like h4 most of
the times we have nice the e4 cross and
opts for some exchanges in the center
and here Mammadov calculates precisely
that this is definitely favorable for
him so we have C capture some d5c
captures Knight captures Bishop captures
Bishop captures and the D captures on e4
so Carson was able to relieve the
pressure in the center but as a result
he has doubled I points now and here you
might go for something like Queen to see
for the pressure f7 as the night is
already nicely pressuring f7 now but if
you do this then blink black can
eliminate the knight on e5 and after D
captors I mean 5 now White has doubled
pawns as well and although white still
has a very nice bishop here a dark
square bishop and black it does have
some dark square weaknesses it's not all
that great for white so here Amamiya
really shows some extreme class and he
goes for night Queen to b5 first so now
he guards the night Bishop captures
would met with Queen captures and black
would simply give up the bishop without
even doubling White's pawns and also
this comes with a threat of Queen
captures on b7 so rook to b8 displayed
and now comes Queen to c4 so now my
media of pressure score since f7 pawn
offers cross and grabbed a knight on e5
and double his pawns but it was very
important to bring the rook from a8 to
Elise to a less active square there is a
b8 okay but should captures pawn
captures and Queen to d3 now cousin does
have doubled pawns now as well
White has doubled pawns as well and now
cross an offer the Queen trade of course
mama doesn't want to capture and under
both cousins pawns so rook a to C 1 and
this is the move that's important for
you to realize was made possible by
moving this rook from A to B 8 now this
rook to AC rocket to c1 is possible we
have Queen captures rook captures and
now okay
Constance rook is now on a not so not so
active a square but cousin does have a
problem here how does he activate the
night there really aren't any squares
how do you get this Knight back into the
game Carson finds an excellent maneuver
he plays B 5 B Phi with the idea that if
you capture on e4 then you get B for
pushing the bishop back after Bishop
goes back now comes Knight to c5
attacking the rook after the rook moves
let's a look at for Knight captors on v3
cousin would create a very powerful
passed pawn here
so after b5 rook to c6 is played
attacking Carson's night and now of
course not before if you play before
with an idea of exchanging the funny
night for the bishop you would lose the
game because after Bishop to b2 the
knight has nowhere to go
even if you guard it to look to a1 is
coming still your knight is lost so it
will look to c6 rook to a8 was played
now cousin defense tonight and also
prepares to bring it back to b8 rook F 2
c1
Medea of doubles up on the sefa nice to
be 8 and now comes rook to c8 offering
offering to trade rooks King to f8 we
have Bishop to b4 as the bishop on e3
was under attack Knight to a6 and now
rook captures an a8 rook captures an a8
and now again a wonderful move by mommy
Yara of Bishop to a5 again not allowing
this knife to enter the game you can't
enter it because the bishop is guarding
here the rook is guarding the C file and
the Knights the b8 would of course be
met with rook to c8 check King here and
now after before cousin species would be
completely blocked you can't move the
knight because you lose the rook you
can't move the room because you'll lose
the night this would be easily winning
for white okay after Bishop to a5 cousin
plays rook to e8 working 28 we have
roped the c6 now and here comes King to
d7 attacking the rook rook to b6 and now
comes nice to see 5 attacking mama da
Rosa bishop we have before and now
Knight to d3 and here okay you could
capture on b5 let's say rook captures
only 5 then King comes
six threatens to grab d5 pawn and here
black will grab the pawn and white
although wood white would have a past be
pawn he would not be able be able to
push it all the way and even if he tries
to protect the e5 pawn then you get to
Roque one check King moves and after
okay tune here it's a white who would be
in trouble
so after room d3 we have e six first
width check a very nice move by mami
Europe that triples blacks pawns
so now Carlson has a has tripled a pawns
and only not plays the rook captures on
b5 so although the material on the board
is equal cousin has tripled pawns
so can ma media have used this to his
advantage
well cousin goes rook to c8 of course
putting a rock on an open file prepares
to ring the rook over to c1 we have King
to be a roof to b7 check King to d6 and
now b5 mama Yahoo starts pushing his
passed pawn rook to c1 check King to g2
and the now rook to c2 Mamedov allows
this and there's a good reason why he
allows it he plays came to g1 now of
course cousin can repeat moves would
work to see one but it's very
interesting what would happen if you
capture the pawn
the problem with capturing the pawn for
example rook captures on f2 is Bishop to
b4 check you have to move the King King
d5 now comes Luke to d7 check King moves
and now comes Luke captures on d3
removing the defender of the rook on f2
captures captures rook on f2 and after
King captures Bishop now we start
pushing your past pawn and after King
protects the D points of the D pawn can
be pushed as well now we have C 7 d 2
white gets a queen black gets a queen
and okay black is up upon but it's a
completely drawn endgame there is no way
to push for advantage here for either
sides so after King to g1 as we saw rook
captures and f2 is impossible but what
about Knight captures on f2 could cross
and grab the F pawn with the night well
again we get Bishop to b4 check King
moves now comes b6 and now it will be
very hard to prevent the advancement of
the of the b-pawn as the cousin did lose
a lot of time by playing Knight captures
on f2 the rook has stayed there to
protect the night or if you move the
knight let's say nourished
check King moves now you bring the king
over rook captures on e7 rope to c1
check King moves and after rook to be
one attacking the bishop of Bishop can
always come to c5 protect the pawn the
pawn can come to be 7 because the rook
is guarding b7 and of course Bishop can
go to d6 and guarded the queening square
so wife would be winning here so Carlson
calculates precisely he does not go for
anything captures f2 rather he pushes g5
he wants to push g4 and do not allow
Mammadov scheme to enter the game by
either f3 or h3 we have a rook to b8 and
then out comes rook to be two of course
you have to put your look behind the
past bond whether it's your own pawn or
your opponent's pawn rook to d8 check
King c5 and now b6 cousin goes rook the
b5 attacks the Madeira Bishop a we have
King to g2 and now we have g4 if you did
something like rook captures on a5 of
course this does not work because of
simply b7 there's no way to prevent the
promotion here you would have to go Ruby
5 and then after while you get the Queen
you have to give up your rook what is up
the exchange and winning this game
easily so after King G 2 G 4 by Carlsen
we have h3 and here it's a very
interesting moment in the game here
Carlson played
h5 and this was a move for t1 so time
control has been reached already I don't
know if anyone saw the live coverage
yesterday I was too busy you know are
trying to figure out that email from the
st. Lewis chess club but if any of you
have seen the live coverage you know do
share in the comments if maybe there was
an interview with with the players after
the game but it's very interesting why
why not GG actors on h3 for example King
captures on h3 and now Knight captures
on f2 we check King moves and now nice
to d3 cousin would be up a pawn ok he
still has a Triple D pawn the rook is
preventing this point from ever reaching
b7 as b7 is a light square so it's very
interesting
why cost and decided not to go for this
it doesn't seem to be all that much
white can do here after the King moves
wherever the rook would be guarding the
5th rank so the King will not be able to
advance up the board seems like a very
nice position for
so I'm very interested in this now but
okay after H 3 H 5 was played H chapters
on g4 h chapters on g4 and Bishop to c3
now we have E 5 a very nice move there's
always time to capture the b6 pawn if
you captured with the king then Mamedov
will exchange rooks and you know it's
pretty much a drone endgame so across
and first tries to improve he pushes a 5
and now you get this position where
Coulson has a point on a light square
that guards his knight that also on a
light squared the knife from the lights
where guards this ePHI point that's on a
dark square this point is on a light
square and this point will be pushed on
to a white square so mamuro's dark
square bishop will pretty much be
useless here so cross and could use this
to his advantage if he can activate his
rook but if he can't activate this rook
if ma meter will be able to exchange
rooks then even would all disadvantage
against the bishop Coulson will not be
able to push for advantage so Rock to g8
was played among your threatens the g4
pawn and here we have King to see for
attacking mama dr of the bishop here
Carlsen tries to infiltrate word to the
king if he manages to get to the King
behind the rook and capture the beasts
exponent with the rook then perhaps he
could to do something he doesn't want to
capture the point immediately and allow
rook captures on g4 then this point
would be threatened as well
so after king c4 mom never goes back
rook to CH check King to d5 and now roof
to DA to check King the c5 rook to see a
check and here cousin doesn't feel like
going back back and forth again he
decides to play King captures on b6
finally a mommy job now as planned
exchanges rooks rugby 8 check King moves
rook capture skin captures and then out
comes King to f1 after trying to
activate his King but cousin goes King
gay for kinky to now comes ecigs as
planned so now you have this position
where white there is no chance for
whites to ever make a pawn move white
has the black has these pawns on light
squares and the only pawn on a dark
square is guarded by a knight that's
analyte square so the bishop is
completely useless here but so is the
night really I mean you can't move the
knight because you'll lose the 5.0 the
e5 pawn isn't as real
an important point but again there's no
way to get closer with the king king to
f1 was played King B 3 King play five
King c2 King he to your coffin played
but Knight to the c1 with Czech king he
one night the three check king e two
night c1 sure King you won and here
after repeating the position for three
times the players agreed to a draw so I
mean it's really I don't think any I
haven't to put it like through a really
deep analysis but I believe no no
mistakes or no inaccuracies were made in
this game by either player so really
does seem like a perfect game
and I forgot I did have a nice photo
challenge prepared for you but I didn't
throw it at the beginning of the video
so now we'll see who lasts till the end
of the video so who are the gentlemen in
the photo here with Magnus Carlsen one
of them is a famous bass player of a
certain famous band so best of luck to
everyone and yeah I would like to thank
Christopher Gleason Mitchell freed field
Erica K Dickinson Troy Haskin and
johannes de rita refer a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and i will keep you informed about
what's what's going on with the st.
louis chess channel and that accusation
i received about copyright infringement
thank you all and I'll see you soon